anstoß komm runter bestimmte store zu
die ersten infos kuchen droppen weil die
spielberger kaputtgehen probleme bei der
kundgebung jetzt der finalen aufs tor
der ball war nicht drin dabei aber nicht
drin nein die beide türen sich
gegenseitig ist herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge timo jakits das ist
ein format was ich schon lange lange
lange nicht mehr gebracht habt aber ich
habe wieder ein bisschen bock darauf das
zu machen was ein bisschen bock die
richtig bock was zu machen und das
funktioniert folgendermaßen ich werde
jetzt sehr sehr viele runden spielen
sehr viele runden davon werden nicht
lustig sein aber die die lustig sind die
suche ich euch raus und schneidet ihr
euch zusammen und wie immer gibt es das
beste beziehungsweise das lustigste kit
am ende des videos völlig ganzer werden
der vielleicht zwei platziert man weiß
es nicht auf jeden fall würde ich sagen
wir springen jetzt direkt mal rein
welches video gefällt können natürlich
die daumen nach oben da lassen leute das
wird heute eine variation das heißt ich
werde
neben den ganzen schrägen cryptbox kit
was es alles gibt werde ich heute auch
ein paar klassische pvp kids mit
reinnehmen wie zum beispiel das hier und
die gelegenheit nutzen um ein bisschen
zu rasseln rasseln sehr schön da
gelassen
green green goes green screen von
twitter noch nicht machen screen combo
of doom allah jetzt frisst er die combo
of doom jetzt gleich das stück mit dem
schild der sich verzweifelt kommen ja
komm her und es dann vom vater mitch sie
hey leute was ist das event geht das
schwert heißt schon mal es ist krieg
könnte das vielleicht ein zuschauer von
mir sein
es schmeckt gut bucket spawn man kann
places upon you better es okay was kann
mein team haben du bist weiter oben
runter das gefährlich macht den freaks
die selige pass auf ich immer sehen was
das hier ist heißen guardian dafür
greift ihn an kraft irland dessen böse
hallo myspace place place wir noch das
jetzt kein schlechterer länger dauern
wir danken wenn ich mal schaden da
glaube ich bei uns nicht anders sein
tja was dr chris martin stockinger es
wird richtig rasiert von places
er wird richtig rasiert aber ich das
nicht ins wasser gelassen ins wasser du
kannst dich nicht ab kannst dich nicht
doch keiner muss doch alle branche
wieder danke alte richtiges kleines team
und dem places nice es down ok
jahrhunderts kitten bogel mit power 84
atmosphäre die rüstung protection zwei
bis drei dia und allen gemixt testen wir
mal alle gegner ist ein killer laut name
zumindest mal vielleicht können wir uns
noch ein bisschen durch schießen können
wir nicht
alter schwede was war das für eine combo
alter what the [ __ ] okay ja alter
schwede was war das für eine combo noch
jemand kommt also 1.8 pvp zeigt sich
wieder von seiner besten seite
einfach nur die wildesten combos
vollkommen sinnlos mir so eine 4,5 mal
combo wobei er hat mir seine sechs
kollegen habe ich sehr schön
ok also eine kleine challenge ein gegner
mit dem bogen der du verlierst teils mit
power 52 flame 1 und infiniti 1 will
dazu einen fall und dirigent verliert
hier leitet den ersten schon mal das war
schon richtig lange vor mir
das bin ich im wasser wasser ist kacke
noch einer ok den habe ich blind
getroffen
sehr schön noch ein noch etwas macht er
nicht richtig killen nicht fehlen egal
wer verliert jetzt
was machen die leute heute ich dachte
schon die menschen hätten hier ihren
humor verloren
aber weit gefehlt hier haben wir doch
mal ein paar ganz nette sachen nämlich
hier eine schminkecke und sieht aus wie
so ein höhlenmensch das passte perfekt
dieser knochen dazu so eine richtige
höhlenmensch alter weiß was macht erst
als ob die ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
oh ja
warum bewegt sich das nicht das bewegt
sich nicht es bewegt sich nicht kann man
das ich glaube man kann die kannst dich
steuern kopf ist richtig aber leider
keine antwort mehr konnte konstant haye
kam anders stand lopez gibt es legale
schläger alles klar
alles gleich hab mich nicht mal an vw
nicht mal okay nein ich glaub ich hab
ich dann habe ich bin raus ich bin aus
der geschichte heraus nämlich jetzt
gewaltig wie vor ist aber checken was es
hier gibt es gibt hier immer schon okay
das war schon alles klar
unerlässlich für pvp und im online
buchen tatsächlich ok und ein kleines
zum trinken
diese sinnlos ok go go go go mit seinem
mein gott der ad hoc ad hoc in reval dem
eurospeedway mit dem finalkampf man hat
so was von glocken sind aber okay die
sehr schön und hier sehen wir jetzt dass
geht dass ich gegen gemeint habe sie
gesagt ab krieger boxen
ich habe mich hier einmal einiges von
kripo und hier in stick was wir damit
machen werdet ihr sehen ich weiß nicht
was er da vorhatte wenn wir die kripo zu
schießen
warte warte warte wir machen es anders
nein du roi die gehalte warum macht es
doch nicht ändern
warte warte ich warte ich will was
anderes machen
warte warte warte wie oh ich bin nicht
boxen
wir spielen fußball
ein junger boxer zu mir wollen fußball
spielen nein warte warte dorf dann baue
ich die bau ich dir jetzt einfach ein
tor ja wenn du keine lust hast und zwar
so sagt zack zack zack zack
der nervt doch nicht so machen ich muss
doch hat den tor bauen alter ja was
haben sie auch mal so zack zack zack
zack zack zack jugend mich fast nur ist
es zu groß als tor ja okay so groß weil
es ja nicht unfair fühlen machen auch
wenn er einfach komplett ignorant ist ja
nicht mitspielt so alles klar
ok jetzt hier anstoß komm runter anstoß
quote länger juckt ihn nicht alter juli
überhaupt nicht kann er überhaupt
deutsch ali zu hier ich glaube nicht
dass man das könnte richtig coole spiel
werden okay dann nehmen wir das auch mal
als anstoß hier
ok und da vorne ist da vorne ist ein tor
es ist richtig dass nun europas auf es
stimmt auf die gegnerische hälfte zu
drei verteidiger oder drei spielbälle
stellen sie ihm entgegen fünf bälle
wann gab es das zum letzten mal fünf
spiele weil in einem match in einem
menschen fassbar
das tor zu die ersten abfahrts kugel
trocken weil die spielbälle kaputtgehen
problem sich vehement gegen jetzt der
finalen aufs tor der ball war nicht drin
der ball war nicht drin nein die
bildeten sich gegenseitig das gibt's
nicht okay er macht jetzt ganz geschickt
nein jetzt kommt jetzt kommt der
gegenspieler mit rein
der gegenspieler von mit rein ok macht
er ganz macht er das geschickt aber er
verlässt dafür nachhaltig seiner
defensive und jetzt der ball ist auf der
linie museum noch reinmachen
das ist nicht so leicht aber jetzt hier
die finale gelegenheit kurzer distanz
kurzer distanz alles drin
10 wir müssen in kürze geben
hallo leute wie einfach ein junger gott
ich bin sowas von tot
doch nicht erst gestorben nein